tell me what the Democrats are running
on the Democrats have nothing - Ronald -
they resorted to great systems and a
forbid all these other things
african-american unemployment Hispanic
unemployment record lows this election
cycle is about the highest stakes
impossible product
Farmageddon you know this is tough stuff
we're fighting a war
well that's a clip from the film trumpet
war the new documentary from former
White House chief strategist Steve
Bannon and president Trump's enemies are
seemingly emboldened after the release
of details from the Woodward book and
that anonymous New York Times op-ed by a
senior administration official Bannon
says President Trump is now facing what
is essentially a coup from within his
own white house he joins us now with
more you can see the film Wednesday on
the one America news network it's gonna
be a lot of fun 8 p.m.
I don't man hey long time no see thanks
for having me thanks for dressing up you
have your own clothing line coming out
right it's black on black or they wanted
the military I knew and knew if I was
gonna come on the show you were going to
bust my child I needed the military
jacket tonight because it's at war
you're at war so you got to be in the
military coat all right why the film why
now I mean it's it we're at war we've
been at war from the beginning and we're
top ads against for a minute Polanco
play right I've talked about this for
years you know I've been on your radio
show you're on on my radio show Trump
has been award the permanent political
class I about eight months ago I started
this film feeling that by the time we
had to run up it was gonna be like the
Tea Party movement we needed these rally
films to kind of get people in power so
this film is for the base plus to get
them excited to get them out you know
walking precincts etc so I think it's
you know you can already tell it's got a
big reaction already from the Democratic
lab well the funny thing is is that it's
coming out Wednesday when you had morosa
would weigh it Michael Wolfe
Omarosa Woodward and now the anonymous
column and there are some out there say
this is all planned I mean I'll plan a
coordinated but I almost would think it
would be given that it's every day it's
a drip drip drip the film shows what
president Trump's been up against since
day one right it shows in the campaign
but particularly shows in the White
House what he is up against and I think
the convergence of that book in the
anonymous column I mean it's quite
evident that President Trump there's a
coup I mean there's a coup like they're
the same there was a coup by general
McClellan in the senior leadership in
the Union Army to try to thwart what
Abraham Lincoln wanted to do in the
Civil War you have an exact type of coup
right now what was said in that
anonymous letter was absolutely
outrageous and I think
president take immediate and direct
action to to find out who the
conspirators are I don't think there's
any one author I think there's an author
that I think there's address somebody
that drafted it there are many voices in
there I think you can tell the way it's
written I think that's a much broader
conspiracy than people think I think
it's probably six to a dozen people and
I think you ought immediately start to
do it Andrew Jackson did I do what
Abraham Lincoln did find out who's
responsible and fire him
oh yeah Broadway actress is now
basically wishing that John Wilkes Booth
was still we're still around I mean this
is this is the this is the level of
discourse and dialogue that they always
blame Trump for when they say well he's
the one who I said you can go punch
someone out at rally you can see you can
see in the first I have a prologue in
this film that's five minutes long if
this was put into theaters because who
is going to be distributed otherwise it
would probably be almost x-rated for
violence and language what we did is
went back to the rallies we went back to
what and tifa's done to the Trump
supporters we show the violence I mean
the the the left is out of control right
now okay across the board is it by any
means necessary
they are absolutely any means necessary
and now they have cohorts now they have
cohorts in the administration and I
think it's broader than the White House
remember what the New York Times said
was senior administration officials and
what that basically means for the New
York Times is cabinet secretaries in
their deputies major agency heads in
assistance to the president which is
about 40 to 50 people nikki Haley came
out with an op-ed in The New York Times
where she basically it was supportive of
the president but it basically said when
I chant what I want to challenge the
president I do so directly to his face
and there was word that the president
didn't like that that much because like
why do you have to write a column with
that with that focus again it was fairly
it was fairly positive toward the
president but pointing out she disagrees
with him on key issues when I worked for
the Reagan administration it wasn't so
out there constantly that you had you
know perpetual infighting although there
were people who were less conservative
than Reagan
movement there was more of a sense of a
movement I don't know when Jim Baker and
come on with Jim Baker
and then towards the end of the first
term of the second term you had you had
the knives being put into the
conservatives everyday white houses are
naturally you know call them the
cauldron cauldrons of opinions etc but
that's okay because Trump does like
people with different different opinions
and in the end did Cohen Gary Cohen get
his way on trade he did not know I by
the way light eyes are dead by the way
that's the power of rock did I said the
date of Politico what President
trumpeter do in the book is buy a
million copies and airdrop him into the
congressional districts we've got to win
here's what it shows that President
Trump had the right idea from the
beginning he understands where an
economic war with China and he's going
to bring all forces of the government to
bear in that economic war Cohen an
importer and all this crowd that farted
the committee to save America which the
book is basically the typed up notes the
two central parts the worgen economic
war against China and Afghanistan in
which the president was lie that he was
lied to and it was misled about the cost
of Afghanistan and what type of control
we had over the country Afghan that's
why Maddox just went to Afghanistan
they're trying to bail themselves up by
the way they were not upfront they were
not upfront and truthful to the
president itíd states and so if you look
at and they say in there that he has the
temperament of a five year old I told
Politico today if that's a five year old
I want more fun I want more five years
on the National Security Council here's
a guy that has in everything they say in
the book about his trade policies that
can our voice dead wrong Obama's taking
credit for the economy you got you got
this manufacturing boom blue-collar jobs
wages going up for the for the for the
lowest wage workers they said it would
never happen it's happening he's killing
it on the jobs front Obama's taking
credit on Friday by the way not just
Obama but also the Bush administration
let's let's be burly and a not a lot of
taken credit a lot of a lot of the
anonymous are but are people from the
Bush administration establishment
Republicans the rest out Republicans and
the Democrats have been about managed
declined to the United States of America
president Trump is a disrupter he's an
innovator and this is what drives him
nuts because of his policy and what he's
doing is reorienting the world's supply
chain back to the United States that's
why Mexico is just cut a deal with us
that's why the EU is going to cut a deal
with us that's why Korea and Japan are
going to cut deals with us he's winning
he is
he's a absolute economic nationalist
absolutely you can tell what he's doing
on trade he's bringing jobs back in just
like he said he's gonna do they hate
that goldman sachs gary corny these guys
are they are the Investor Relations
Department of the Chinese Russian all
bought into China
honey but their chips are on some what
they told Trump is that the rise of
China is like the second lamentable
inevitable is it's like the second law
of thermodynamics it's some law of
physics it can't be capable around and
Trump said that's not true and he's been
relentless the book opens where they're
stealing they're taken off his desk the
the the a deal about NAFTA and about
Korea eventually and they said was
terrible Trump didn't know eventually he
got around to it
he renegotiated NAFTA he renegotiated
Korea and he's renegotiating in the
process of taking of taking the supply
chain back from I was Omarosa hired she
was on the campaign and that Bob way
Amuro so it was very girls campaign very
boy that was she was very effective on
the campaign she did a terrific job we
had to throw Omarosa into some very
tough situations and I think that's why
they've been taping conversation well I
think that's why rights and they look in
hindsight but rights and people I think
not a straightforward decision looking
forward to stay in the film looking
forward yeah well I can't wait to see
brought that one go-to trumpet war doc
from Qualcomm and you can find out more
you can watch a trailer if you haven't
seen it already a lot of you already
have